la joie est
ET Aie
Salut amour, je suis dans le métro de nulle part bien sûr
carte de métro
je l'ai trouvé ici
et
ceux avec des filles YouTube il en a trouvé une
temps
c'est qu'il restait le nombre de jeux de Mariana
quelle vie
je peux y aller
ET Aie
C'est
triste à dire mais appelez d'ici comme ça
passer par YouTube pur
naviguer dans un texte ne souffrira que
Je ne veux pas mourir juste ici et
J'affronte la tristesse avec le
nature
ta chaîne de solitude
C'est
de mon de Frida à mon âme alors ressens
le mélange
ET Aie
le
chemin strictement perdu donc vous
passé par mon plus grand des purs
naviguer entre 12 en prendre un ne fera que souffrir
le
mourir serpents cet endroit est
O
pas de shampoing
ET Aie
l'or miné perdu que je ressens
passer à travers le bruit que tu traverses
parcourir parmi les autres prendre le seul départ
souffre que tu ne veuilles pas mourir pour ça
lieu
je ne suis qu'un endroit
style de couleur et
Hé
Luiz à
et Joyeux anniversaire